[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED: Hi, I'm Ed, and I'm from
the Google Maps API Team
and we're here in Hamburg
today to hack on solutions
for newly arrived refugees.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL PLETZIGER: Ubilabs
and Google teamed up
to come up with this project
idea called Refugee Maps
and this was kind the moment
when the idea for the hackathon
was born.
MARTIN KLEPPE: We
want to have something
where we put in related points
of interest for refugees.
THOMAS STEINER: So what
is the actual problem
that refugees are facing
while they're on the road?
The most needed thing
is local information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: We're working on
the passion project for Google
Maps and it's my job to optimize
it for Arabic languages.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: What
we're planning to do
is to add the functionality
to actually propose
new points of interest so
the volunteers don't have
to do all the work with
finding out the places that are
interesting for the refugees.
[MUSIC PLAYING]